like you know that punch thing yeah if
you like whip it it'll go higher well
like I think it just measures the
initial thing because I just did it give
give chin the breakdown you Brian your
stupid strength thing so this is a
strength thing I did um you did nine I
did 100 my best is 119 on this stupid
thing but I just did 109. Brandon's
first time was 198. George did 142. Big
Crow at yes sir and Casey did zero no
I'm 50. I think it was one I beat my
meat with this same hand
think about that so I I like bringing
that because it [__] everybody out yeah
that's what happens in practice in case
keep practicing
it didn't record my first one that would
have been the best one well congrats
case
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby I I had a friend I watched
him I watched this band and I I go uh he
was such a character I watched his band
and recently like no this is you're we
were just having a conversation about
people who who just have no father I
watched this guy he's he's in a band he
plays his thing and um and I was like it
was good it was all right and I go uh
but he was playing covers and I go you
write your own music goes yeah I do you
know I go well you why didn't you guys
play some of your you know your own
songs you want to be a musician you got
to come up with your own self he goes
yeah we do I mean you know right you
know I go when are you right I mean when
you guys practice he goes practice I go
when you guys practice the man he goes
we don't practice
I like this you don't practice and I go
but wait you don't so you don't get
together and rehearse like writing songs
he goes no dude I don't I don't have to
practice like oh first show I do like
when we get back I might be a little
wobbly but over that I'm like okay I
remember just going I am no longer going
to talk to you because you will never do
the things I I thought you were a
musician who was actually trying to make
it I was like oh well you know Aerosmith
been doing I don't know 60 years you
know they rehearse oh dude but you guys
are good dude and Leonard Skinner does
all documentary on them writing songs
but they would meet the the doors
everybody who wrote those songs every
day every day I was like I was talking
to Comic he's like I don't do spots
around 10 minutes and I don't do spots
around town there's no reason for you
Lucy kid's been doing I think 35 years
38 years you know he still does 38 years
that that probably still the spot that
podcast from Rogan's very enlightening I
sent it to a bunch of young Comics I was
like this is not good insights but it's
not yeah because there's the comics like
who are super out there and super famous
like Rogan Burr who are like write it
down on paper never forget it get home
and I'm writing writing writing I'm not
that way and a lot of comics aren't just
same way in school like some people are
visual Learners whatever like you
there's a certain way to learn right
what Louis writes on stage but he's also
like I get an idea in my head I'll write
that word down and then I figure out
okay that's how I do that's a lot of
common a lot of comics do it then some
can there's no right or wrong way as
long as you're doing it and then him
talking about the way like he has a
kernel and he'll just eat dick bomb bomb
bomb and eventually come out like in a
lot of comments you know it's been
scared to do that because you want to go
on kill because you're worried about
what people are thinking Louie just
doesn't give a [__] dude when Louie
Louin wrote it made me laugh so bad when
Lou and Rogan because they're Polar
Opposites when it comes like taking care
of their bodies and just like life and
the discipline when it comes to like you
know the gym and stuff and Rhoden goes I
don't know if you saw uh Andrew humor
and they're talking about cold time I'm
like I don't want nobody's talking about
cold top with uh Louis but I think Lewis
talking about he he's talking about coal
plunges and hot plunges yes oh my God
stupid
what kind of Life do you have when you
have to get into a cold bath and then a
hot bath and actually have a
conversation about it I was like yeah
I'm listening to it I was driving I was
like he goes you're not he goes I got
super awkward I was like not me I was
like get him he's like you're not living
reality he's like you're above Earth
you're in this weird Stratosphere up
here while everybody else nobody can
relate to that because Rogan's Brogan
had a good answer too though because he
goes if you have a human body you don't
want your body in the way you want your
body to work optimally but that can be
its own job you know that could be its
own job it was right users like how well
is your life going where you're debating
about cold plants I think he's so right
he's like humans aren't made to do that
either I think it's funny I remember
when a lot of people when when cryo was
all the rage and I was in the cryo and
Rogan's in the cryovers and cryo you
guys always gave me [__] where everybody
was in the cryo and cryo had its own
thing and I remember you quietly said to
me you go
um you were biting your nail you go you
go like this you go um we're on it I
don't believe in it I go I go what oh
and you were like no I mean I don't know
I just played Sports my whole life and I
just know we all sat in ice baths but
cryo I don't think it works dude and how
many how many crowds are around now now
it's all gone everyone's doing cold
plunges yeah which again is not
Reinventing the wheel that's been around
since the 50s when people were doing
sports way before that for inflammation
stuff like that now I don't know about
how the new trend doing it every day
start your Mooring off with it hey watch
this it's just a discipline I don't care
but just yeah me neither I don't care no
I I really don't get it I do I do like
getting cold water and there's crazy
benefits to it I don't know about doing
every day I think if you're disciplined
enough to set up a cold tub and go into
every day it's more of a discipline
thing to get your day started it'd be no
different whether I am running 20
Sprints every morning that's me just as
healthy for you well they do say that a
cold shower or cold plus 100 a lot
better for you a lot of benefits but I
don't care I mean I do it sometimes
sometimes I'll do it but most of the
time I don't care I would do it if it
was at my house I'd jump in it yeah I'm
gonna take a real quick shower then I'm
gonna go play with my kids yeah it's too
much of a ordeal I actually don't care
about living to 100. that's yeah no me
neither I don't and I really don't they
tell you the cold plunge ain't gonna get
you 100 I don't think so no there's been
there's bigger issues in our lives I I
think yeah
yeah that's that's uh I actually think
that if you make it your job to try to
live to 100
something might happen yeah well I think
if it's your job lived 100 you're really
not enjoying life to the full so people
you have that anxiety right yeah also
super healthy people die all the time
and my favorite is that there is this
[__] these memes on motivation people
like United [__] and and uh this I
can't remember who it was said Hey
listen there are a lot of bodies on
Everest they didn't ever made it down
they all of them froze to death their
bodies are still there because they
can't there the body smells anyway I
don't know how many see how many bodies
are on overseas I promise you every
single one of them was a highly
motivated individual crazy so let's take
it down yeah and it was so great but
also if if your things do cold plunge
every day like that like 200 bodies yeah
of course you can't get them out yeah
every day which I respect them
discipline pardon it is healthy for you
every other
every other thing in your life better be
on [__] point your diet better be on
point your sleep better be well those
are way more important than Copeland's
your diet baby on [__] point your
sleep better be on point your the way
you structure your day better around
Point Cold plus your relationship
I can't emphasize this enough the least
of my [__] concerns in my life
but the the other things you're trying
your best yes yes and also also I think
the other thing to keep in mind is that
a lot of times how you live your life
your relationships the quality of your
relationships they have found yeah and
your friendship and your community have
as much to do with how long you live as
everything else yeah agree happiness
because that the people of uh
oh [__] who is that what's that town in
uh happiest people yeah what's that town
in Japan right no it's in Phil it was in
the outliers oh in Philadelphia yeah in
Pennsylvania and it's scarpetto is that
what it is maybe happiest town in
America because that happens aren't they
it's the Japanese and they do Rice [__]
what is that book no no not outliers
that's what he talks about it
um Rosetta I think it's called Rosetta
is down in America with lard they were
fat they were but they had amazing
communities but they all none of them
died of heart disease none of them
really it was epidemic in the 50s yeah
so you don't know the story oh it's
[__] great hold on oh there you go no
dude I've been to Bellevue that's why I
saw Seattle yeah yeah I think in 1997
now it's the purge so scarpetto was
amazing because so so
hard disease in the 50s was epidemic so
men in their 40s and 50s were dying all
the time heart disease okay smoking
drinking bad food all that stuff right
it was it was a true epidemic in America
heart disease number one killer still I
believe in America among certainly men
do you know that hard disease right so
so there's this town There's this town
where people are they're from one part
of Italy okay and they're from this one
town it was a it was a rock quarry life
was hard they had to trudge up the
mountain come back down [__] like that
so they they leave the old country come
to America where there's actually a
marble query so they go by and do exact
same thing they set up their Town
exactly the same way this doctor he's in
his 30s and he he's he's studying like
heart disease and he goes there and he
sees a lot of old people and they're fat
they're cooking with lard with pigs
they've got Smiles on their face and
he's like but none of them he was doing
he was checking up the whole town like
you know and he goes none of these
people they're all dying of old days
none of them are dying heart disease
none of them what the [__] is going on
it was the first time that they found
that
um there was something about Community
like all of them would wave to each
other and knew each other that even the
people who were like you know they'd
have like the loser of the town they
took care of him everybody was taken
care of you you had you stopped your day
and they lived exactly the way they did
in Italy and they that was the first
time they realized that a community a
good healthy Community with connective
tissue is just how long ago did he do
that research in the 50s I was gonna say
before cell phones yeah yeah yeah [__]
yeah yeah dude it's toxic yeah what
would we do headphones are talking
without podcasts what would we do it'd
be it would be so long I would barely
just like just like the rest of the
people like just isolate like you know
I'm not gonna drug when I talked this
morning but maybe once a week other than
that I talked to Theo once a week I see
deleted because of the show but it's
like you'd be your you just you know
text here and there but in general just
be your small circle I know ain't a
bummer yeah really weird
really weird but it is what it is
discover top 10 happiest countries in
the world to visit uh Finland Denmark
Iceland Switzerland Netherlands well
Finland there's a part of Finland where
they die everybody dies like laplanders
die like like at 10 from they nothing
but reindeer sausage look up and they
die from the rainbow why they all have
heart disease I think they live just on
because of cholesterol all they eat is
sausage
fart Lapland Finland yeah they have a
really low life expectancy
but some of those places like some place
like the mountains in Germany and stuff
I look at it like no I don't go to the
winter don't get twisted but some of it
I was looking at Hitler's old cribs out
there man they're like on the top of
these mountains it's gorgeous it's
gorgeous that's the Swiss Alps in
Germany I'd love I'd love to go out
there yeah I'd love to tour out there so
then you can do it like all right visit
the current that's the whole thing I did
that that was a that's it [__]
82. it's all good
just it must be someone else used to be
there how about yesterday so tiger kind
of has a kind of a cough but he has he
has uh asthma because he had um
he had uh what's he called pneumonia
when he was a kid really [__] his
lungs up I didn't post about you I would
never post about this I don't know did
my son being sick hey everybody look at
him sure uh no hell no so he had um
uh he had pneumonia was a kid and he had
to get like an x-ray on his lungs and
stuff so once you have that as a kid
kind of [__] your lungs up so he has a
hard time breathing sometimes we get
sick when he's playing sports you don't
need inhaler he's fine thank God but
then he starts with a cop yesterday and
I was like yeah you should be all right
for school buddy drop him off at school
one o'clock teachers like Kate you need
to come pick up tiger I'm like what like
his fever's 104.5 which is not good out
over 103 is [__] trouble yeah 105
you're in deep trouble yeah 104.5 uh
he's dizzy he's been throwing up and
it's not good come pick him up so I go
get him and the nurse was like Hey
listen because of his asthma and stuff
and the the prior history of pneumonia
you can hear him wheezing he's taking
the emergency room like what like with
104.5 temperature given the emergency
room like oh my God it gives temperature
like this is not good which is 105 we're
in some serious trouble here I'm like
and I'm like oh my [__] God then the
nurse like a lot of parents you know
with with medications or shots stuff I
don't know how I'm like bring out the
[__] sauce whatever it is I don't
whatever gets them back healthy the
human antibiotics right away is fever
right now yeah fever what was it an
infection or something we don't know
gets the 99 they test them for
um covid the flu and what's that other
RVs whatever that's hurting kids right
now yeah he checked uh negative for all
that so he's fine give him some
antibiotics instead of caught a bug man
I don't know man what scared the [__]
finally no no school today but he's fine
yeah he's fine but then this morning his
favorite
I hate to think about the fish but his
favorite it's not even a fish it's a
it's a lobster we have a blue lobster
sure you have lobsters I forgot about
yeah his name's Bluey a lot of people
think you just have fish but what they
should no I like that you also have
Crustaceans blue he passed away did he
Bowie passed away and Tiger goes dad
Blue's not moving I go yeah he's a
lobster dude he's not that active and I
look in he's like I don't even he's like
this oh boy and bossy goes then Boston
loves uh blue he goes where's blue I'm
like
why are you swimming upside down
oh man uh how you feeling buddy I'm
feeling better you're right right your
batteries yeah where your Lobster died
because he's dead yeah so I put my hand
on him so I'm like look he's not alive
and then tiger starts his eyes start to
swelling I see him starts crying and
bossy goes Dad what's wrong with blue
I'm like yeah he died and he goes Blues
like this and just made everybody
laughing you know Boston Studios Blue's
like uh I'm gonna start laughing and I'm
like thank god dude thanks for the
comments why did Bluey die no I don't
care no I can't figure it out I don't
know no I don't know we've had two
lobsters yeah we used to have three sure
and the the cichlids ate their claws off
they're like hold on you can keep
Pinterest with those say less you're at
Red Lobster [__] and it's scampi it's
scampi now it's all you can eat on your
arms and they went honk took them away
and then I was like oh wow did Bluey get
killed by a no upper fish who was too
smart he always stayed in the thing too
and they would have ate him I don't know
broken heart because the other two
lobsters I did Howie Mandel's podcast
great fish tank white tables fish tank
great fish you acknowledge that it's a
tank so they gave him that fish tank did
you acknowledge it
Brandon would love this tank he's gonna
come and do our podcast but he so I did
but you know what he had a great fish
tank I wasn't that impressed with the
fish in there they were kind of boring
that was my problem Howie let me help
you out look at that thing is isn't that
beautiful see that coral and [__] like
that's nuts dude
I love Howie that's a legit tank man you
know you know he's a monster on on stage
if you see him do stand up
people could help him until Twisted
because you see him on America again or
whatever and then you saw him on that
show uh was it little monsters with Fred
Savage right yeah before that little
monsters before Bobby big will stand up
his stand-up he's a comedy store guy
like anybody you know from his old
school days he's right there but people
know him as like this oh he's the cool
he's also a hell of a businessman sir oh
stupid he's also a hell of an
entrepreneur great businessman yeah yeah
um monster great a good podcast good
podcast all right yes that's a good time
yeah well he wanted to come on during
the pandemic uh you weren't here I think
you're out of town and they're like yeah
I want to come out here okay and they go
because he's a super germaphobe like do
you notice he only fist bumps you he
doesn't like when people touch him yeah
and uh so he he's like yeah come on he
goes but uh everyone has to wear a mask
I'm like on the pods he's like not
happen I can't do a podcast with mask on
dude I said we're all well I said I'll
get cover test before you come he goes
That's not gonna work is it cool if I
come on but wear a helmet dead serious I
thought he was joking to us we have to
talk about it when he comes on I will
and he's like you've got to come away no
no Howie you can't buddy let's just push
it let's wait till he likes it the
vaccine comes out yeah he's great he's
the best great guy and he's like okay
how about you come to mind and then you
um let's just push it till this thing
passes by and we'll get back the whole
family works with him married 42 years
his son his son his producer I know his
son two daughters yeah great dude great
great great monster Comic man and then
think about all the he's printed money
because on America's Got Talent oh yeah
oh that's right oh my God hey B let's
take a little break from chat about who
knows crocodile house Congo River
whatever it is but I won't be at the
Congo River by m in Springfield Missouri
next Friday Saturday Blue Room February
3rd and 4th Naples Florida February 16th
through the 18th Bakersfield California
one night only one show February 23rd
that's almost sold out Brea California
we switch it it's just March 3rd that's
a Friday March 4th is the fight
companion kabas fight Pain for the Jon
Jones fight card with jelly roll uh
Rampage Jackson one big ass special
guest that I'll announce as we get
closer so go get your tickets Breya
Naples and Springfield Missouri is next
week Friday Saturday love it
um Edmonton in Canada comic strip Feb 23
24 March 2 and 3 and 4 Zanies in
Nashville New York New York Sony home
March 11th West Nyack New Jersey Levity
Live March 16 17 18. come get some maybe
you know in 2020 there's over five
million car crashes that's more than 15
000 a day 600 an hour dude what that's a
crazy number the bottom line is if you
drive a car you're probably going to get
yourself into an accident then what
happens is what do you do well when the
Warriors are expensive well you could
well then hold on now they are expensive
but if I'm injured guess what first of
all when you sue somebody after an
injury you're not suing them you're
suing their insurance company that's
something that was made clear to me
um now here's the thing a lot of times
you just want to be made whole okay
there happens to be a company Morgan and
Morgan that has a crazy crazy number of
years of experience things like 30 years
of experience they make it very easy too
you can file a claim with basically like
8 clicks on yourself yeah man if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan Morgan is America's largest
Law Firm injury all right injury law yep
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
more than 800 lawyers ready to get to
work for you with over 15 billion
dollars recovered for clients Morgan
Morgan has proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation yep and it's submittering
submitting an injury claim again with
Morgan Lawrence very easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer in
fact it's basically like ordering
takeout okay you can submit a claim
without ever having to leave the couch
just open up your phone and in eight
clicks or less well you're already done
if you're ever injured in an accident
you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to for the
people.com fighter or dial pound law
that's pound 529 from your cell phone
that's for the people.com fighter or
pound law pound 529 from your cell
oh before we get back to it B it's
almost end of January and hopefully your
your New Year's resolution is still
popping because on it's doing the most
for you they're trying to get you on the
right step tell me what they got dude
they have their um that's all you sail
dude 20 off supplements nutrition temp
stuff select Fitness items 50 off
digital items you can get Alpha Brain
they have the on at six challenge a six
week workout and lifestyle program with
over 36 000 buckaroos and prize money up
for grabs the challenge helps you
connect with others in the honor
community so you can support each other
achieve your goals listen go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k that's on it.com slash f-a-t-k
you get temps off the entire damn site
it's the best supplements on planet
Earth helps you optimize Best Equipment
best digital workouts will she need to
go the Alpha Brain the nootropic the
Black Label kidding me what audit.com
f-a-t-k you're welcome now let's get
back to the program bro my my boys uh oh
my God he's still on my my boy is uh
Michael Davies who created Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire in Britain he's the
head guy producer for Jeopardy now he
puts all this all these shows together
uh America got all this stuff but he's
also what people don't realize that's in
the brilliant ass he's also the head guy
on um
um men in Blazers
you know if you know that podcast but
like there's not that many big soccer
podcasts or football as they say in
England it's not gonna be that many big
uh soccer podcasts Blazers cool huh
um well no no more new fish just so we
get this out of the way
uh I have a well I'm glad you asked
Brian I'm glad you give a [__] about my
fish right I think it's part of the
reason I have psoriasis
um no it's not you're stressing me out
no there's fish is supposed to calm you
down they calm me down when you can
enjoy this nothing relaxing I'll fall
asleep watching them swim yeah the
problem is is getting the fish to the
tank to cycle from ammonia to nitrates I
have to restart the [__] cycle
tomorrow because I have to move the tank
because my girl keeps complaining about
it I have to reset the tank and put it
on I bought it like a really dope stand
and a new filter we do a new filter
doesn't have all the good bacteria so I
have to start from zero so all those
dope fish I bought they're gonna have
new tank syndrome and someone will die
if my flower horn dies I'm gonna drive
my car off the PCH dude yeah dude listen
you are unless you will you buy me you
know what I want for my birthday what
flowerhorn
like 200 bucks how about a dick pic
listen a dick pic dressed as a
flowerhorn yes because you got the big
bumper that's what you're gonna get I
don't have what do you mean a big bump
yeah
and then we'll just put a little fish
face underneath the head and that's
flowerhorn well I would say uh you are a
beginner fish owner so you're gonna kill
your first wave of fish I hired a
professional I have a guy cut a fish
you've been doing it 30 years from
Boston okay nice come in to help me out
oh he's great get him on the puck
I feel like something Rogan would do so
when it comes to fish alkalinity we're
gonna eat at like a restaurant in Austin
be like this guy is the head chef at the
steakhouse and you're like all right
well you'll have a lot I'm in L.A dude
yeah
this guy no he's not the talking type
he's like he we're like you know I'm
watching him do the tank stuff I'm
talking about fish and then he goes you
see him he gets a small guy can be
honest with me I'm not a huge talker
like social guy I'm gonna do this you
mind if I just clean I go oh yeah I was
trying to make you come I felt she was I
was just trying to make you comfortable
he's from Boston like Cardinals dude not
a big talk dude I'm not a big like kind
of yeah I just want to do the work and
he just don't feel like you have to I
was like oh dude that that makes me feel
better I was just trying to make sure
you're comfortable you're in my house I
don't want you [__] with my fish he's
like leave me here dude I'll be done in
an hour I'll let you know when I'm done
are you on some drinks nah I'm fine all
right maintenance then but these great
texts hey how the fish doing how's the
water good good being the third except
the new tank all good hmm
you know you know when someone first
comes your house you just try to like I
didn't want to be down he's in my
theater by himself how many fish have
died
uh
uh three and I have like 25. not bad
your boy when I say B you don't
understand when I say I'm on it I woke
up this morning at four bro because I
can't sleep
right woke up at four before my kids get
up and I do a water change 25 every
morning for those tanks to make sure
those fish don't die you do a water
water change so I have to get a hose
suck all the water the bad water out
take it out condition new water pour it
in
Brian how many times I have three hey
hold on
B
I didn't ask for this
now Rogan God bless him told me when I
go hey dude remember you're super into
fish I'm thinking about getting promised
bad idea of the maintenance I'm like oh
you're crazy you can hire some even if
you have somebody it's still on you 99.
even a full-time fish guy but you know
me I'm a control freak I don't want that
I'm gonna figure out myself I need a
fish staff and then and then the thing
went bad and one when the lobster died
and another fish died my girl goes what
are you doing you have spots over your
body you're stressed out you don't need
this just get rid of it and I go what
kind of message is that to our son you
think because one [__] Oscar goes
belly up I'm gonna give up I'm doubling
down I'm going tomorrow by four fish now
let me ask you a question how much would
you say Howie Mandel's fish tank costs
let me see it I'll tell you right now
and there's there's Coral now
saw a lot of different salt water that's
the Bugatti of fish tanks now now let's
say let's say tank didn't hook him up
he's about that's probably a
500 gallon tank
250 to 500 gallon tank with that I would
say that that's probably a 25 30 000
setup that's a 25 to 30 000 setup let's
see Rick Rossi I mean check out my 300
000 or 700 000 tank went do you have a
blue lobster though
he did DM you yeah didn't respond back
after that oh yeah but you have a blue
lobster [__]
funny joke ding it back no I ruined that
friendship
I'm paying full price at Buffalo Wild
pretty cool
Montana cost about six thousand ten
[__] no way
the smaller ones yeah six ten the the
could cost a million yeah so like I
because I I want to get a saltwater tank
for my birthday to that or new Raptor
Bronco but uh so I'm I'm looking at the
tanks and I ask a guy who's getting your
custom ones and there's a tank I don't
know probably 100 gallon you know not
huge probably the size of this
and then and then up 100 gallon tank
well I'm bored with that I know I go how
much is that
uh just just the equipment no fish it
just set us up not bad about 19 Grand
19 Grand
oh no no I don't want a great white in
there I just want like this yeah 19
Grand just to start 20 grand because I
hear 20 grand I hear 40 to the taxes you
should hear 40 because that's I live my
life you should hear 40 because of taxes
because you can't write off a fish tank
can if it's in studio okay oh if it's in
studio how do you know where it's at
oh
well now they know where it's at
well I'm gonna get one here how many
people in the IRS listen to our podcast
oh I know dude while they're just
[__] people over they're listening to
us
they don't [__] reaching people over
I didn't say that I didn't say that
either dude don't be cool babe
I'm sure people they pay their taxes
that's like no Trump here I pay my taxes
I'm like Elon I pay tax your regular guy
you pay your taxes it's the very least
unless you're Wesley Snipes yeah I've
heard of people not paying for big
people you would know big bands you know
that I've worked with people in the past
didn't pay tax for 10 years and that is
the height of their career so like [__]
it we're just gonna live and buy all our
stuff did they test for 10 years 10
years not a good idea they got that it's
good no hold on it's but you your plan
is let's say let's say you do it for
five years your band's popping we're
just gonna buy all the property spend
all the cash account on good assets and
live our lives and then no in the next
five years you've built all this equity
and all this stuff now you're gonna the
next five years you're working on the
road and you're paying those your your
employees the government you you know
what I'm saying like your boss is the
government so that for five years
they're going Sizzler the next five
you're gonna chill out on that yeah but
those five better be worth it yeah they
better be worth it there's I know a lot
of big bands who have done that tax tax
evasion and tip penalties and all that
now some people out there just like Blue
Collar they never pay never get caught
there's people that never get cut yeah
they don't have the time that they don't
catch them or they're not making enough
to go after them yeah they just don't
become privy to it because in order for
them to catch you something has to
trigger it there are people at a certain
level some has to catch it where they go
hold on you're trying to write off a
Lamborghini as a work truck
and you wrote this card I know a guy who
uh made 500 million dollars and he had a
business manager who never paid his
taxes and he that has no money now
yeah if the because the IRS goes um your
ignorance is not an excuse you owe us
200 million dollars you're something
good you're a really good Fellas thing
where they get in business with that guy
and he has some by the bar his only
problem is getting with him can't not
selling drinks [__] you pay me not
selling food [__] you paid I can't [__]
you [__] you pay me until you got to
burn IRS until you got to burn it down
that shows him it's the [__] Shane
he's like right in the the papers that's
the IRS see well no I'm not as popping
as I was three years [__] you pay me the
mafia comes in IRS he starts creating
all this trouble no like Joe Pesci
starts creating all his running up tabs
beating up the waiters it's all a plan
then he comes to Paulie and says I need
your help Paulie goes well I guess I
could own that what am I gonna do with
the [__] bar what do you mean what do
you ask me you know I don't know about I
don't know I don't know about bars
it was a scam from the beginning yeah
isn't it great that's why he did it
genius who do you want me to kill him he
was yeah I mean it wouldn't be a bad
idea he's so here's what are you asked
me to do you asked me I don't know
anything about bars he said you know
somebody
could be a bar stool you know that yeah
and then they that's how they get their
money true story and destroy a bar it's
a good time set on fire get the
insurance yeah bad idea should we start
a bar and sit on fire yep start a fish
store good luck starting a fire too good
luck trying to get away with that too
nowadays hey what's the what's the what
do you think the margins are on fish I
was thinking about that on uh on say
like a flowerhorn I paid 200 how much
did the store get it for oh you want to
be a fish broker eight dollars be a fish
broker oh yeah for eight dollars same as
like night like these Nikes you pay
whatever 200. that's a good question
because they're getting those fish at
wholesale right
yeah I'm sure that there are places you
go that are fish brokers
I don't know
what is what is the markup on it there
you go what is the markup on aquarium
fish well mostly in stores 120 release
hmm
three percent bump from the wholesaler
wow
that's that's that's astonishing that's
not a good business to be in
aquarium City off Sherman Way there
because I tried buying all these fish
like hold on how long do you have to
take two weeks ago absolutely not we
won't say these fish jokes at least
cycled and six weeks old I go why not
they go could you put those fish in in a
week those fish are gonna die we don't
want our fish dying
and if your fish die you can bring the
body back to them and you get uh the the
refund the fish not your money but you
get another fish if they have it
I stocked my uh pond with uh various koi
and they were all taken I know you just
said that 19 I'll take it dude get some
tougher fish but I wouldn't accept it
you know you can eat like some bass in
there you get trout in there I think
they give a [__] about a raccoon to kill
them no no no a big mouth bass yeah but
it's not a big enough Pond I don't know
what kind of pond you're working with
how many gallons are talking I don't
know
that we can get some gnarly fish in
there where
no listen we all like raccoons they put
their hand there gone
really oh yeah we need some gnarly fish
in there dude really you want me hey
I'll do it for you want me to start you
hey give me a fish to save from a
raccoon in a pond what what fish would
kill a raccoon no fishing oh yeah the
crocodiles we'll get a small alligator
in there the problem is they grow up
promise they grow up and then you can't
get in your front door fish the raccoons
eat oh through there bro koi fish I know
goldfish Crustaceans cats do the same
thing goldfish are stupid dude
goldfish was the sheep of the [__]
fish if you have a goldfish Brian you're
not my friend dude that's for basic
[__]
Steve drops around the perimeter of your
palm will deter raccoons from smacking
in the shallows
I I'm obsessed with crocodiles I'm
afraid of them oh I was getting a lot of
[__] from uh my our boy Lex McMahon
because I said let's go on I said I
don't kill an alligator he's like bro
you know I hunt those monsters
he's like he's like the the Drummond you
can't
is there one thing Nile crocodiles like
I I still I I probably talked about this
but this guy was an adventurer he was
always in his kayak he was always
getting crazy he would he would kayak
down the worst Rapids in Africa he was
always in Africa in the kayak and this
little kayak he did crazy [__] Daredevil
Daredevil finally meets a girl settles
down he's like you know I'm just going
to be settled down I'm not going to do
this [__] anymore because I'm doing
these things I'm gonna die
these two guys say we wanted we want to
go up the Congo and he's like all right
I'll just plan it I'll plan the Congo
River
Now bring up the Congo the river's no
punk it doesn't get as much hype as
denial Congo's no punk ain't no punk
okay that's the deal jungle you know you
know there you go now B you know my aunt
my aunt with her other best friend two
females alone uh-huh sailed the Congo
and the now together what on Abby no no
Sophie packed his wife my aunt whoa
badass well the Congo is uh the Congo
the Republican was a failed country it's
uh everyone's nice there right there's
no extremists there no no five million
people weren't killed in a civil war
there at all five and a half million
people were killed in that Civil War and
the bodies were dumped into the water
into the river now those bodies was that
whites killing blacks or what is it that
was blacks on blacks yes black on black
crime very tribal now now
um what happened yes what happened was
um all those bodies were eaten by
crocodiles five million oh it's Five
Points horrible tragedy 5.5 million and
a lot of those crocodiles when you feed
them like that they get very big sir and
they also get the taste for dick they
also keep growing
Crocs don't really stop growing there's
some kind of a thing well anyway dude
it's nuts how big animals get like like
a fish for instance if you have a 50
gallon tank a bit if you have a 500
gallon tank you know the grow to the to
what tank you put them so if you have a
500 that some fish get [__] massive
go back to that so think about the last
thing about like dinosaurs and other
prehistoric animals they were so [__]
big dude so big
you know what they found in Russia a
rhino who was frozen but he was covered
in here almost all his organs are still
intact they found out it was a woolly
mammoth no it's all right it's just it's
new this just popped off yeah well so
they're coming up chin so homeboy
homeboys coming out with their their
path he knows all the places in the
Congo and he goes you know one more time
just one more oh he's got you a bug one
more always get you good looking dude
South African dude good looking young
guy doesn't matter and they're in the
and they decide let's get in the Congo
with kayaks that are a little bigger
than us they're a little longer than a
human being but barely they're like
little diamond-shaped kayaks shitty
kayaks
and they're just going down look at that
wow Lily Rhino wow are you [__]
melting Tundra
and then apparently all his uh
uncovering the ancient carcasses two
cave lion cubs a bison a horse a baby
woolly rhinoceros and a most intact
woolly mammoth ever found as climate
change continues to see climate change
isn't all bad uh to pull back this
crucial carpet of ice we're bound on
cover more close to where the world's
first report only baby Willie Rhino was
ever found runs have now discovered
another of its kind and this time the
carcass almost 80 percent intact it can
take uh its DNA and cologne yeah bro
we've seen Jurassic Park I know now
back to them what was like the Russians
made woolly uh Rhino jerky yeah the
three of them are paddling down the
Congo please we wrap this up paddling
down the Congo all in the small kayak in
the small kayak in a line and a giant
crocodile 16-foot crocodile
comes up like this and he now you're
only disheved water
do you like this hot the water oh no his
his eyes are like you're here right here
and all the guy goes and he goes oh my
God that's like this oh my God
jumps out of the water grabs him by his
shoulder and they said that it was so
big that it grabbed him by the shoulder
and his sternum and he was probably dead
the minute it bit him because they have
the hardest bite just bit down pulled
him over and he kind of went he didn't
even make a noise he just got broken and
then put him down other people get away
yeah they okay he disappears and they're
like they paddle they go running into
this they go running to this Village in
the middle of the Congo the people like
see these two white guys with paddles
running on them they were like ah and
they all ran into the forest and they
ate them because they finally came back
like holy [__]
yeah it was interesting imagine the
sheer tear that's such a long story but
imagine this [__] so long thank God it's
over right for everybody involved but I
like the ending good ending because
someone died you could have you could
have said guy was no no somebody's got a
canoe long story someone must die Congo
River dude huge great long story someone
I must be laughing dead so I must be
laughing or someone must die but and
this is my thing be imagine the sheer
Terror you feel when that thing's
leaping in the [__] air well that
also don't have don't be in that dumb
kayak the family oh this this difference
everything I've seen so far is uh
someone that was camping and it got
dragged out yeah it's in Australia yeah
Brian made the story
of the canoe the canoe Congo yeah in the
Congo yeah very long time ago yeah no
recently or hey or look at me fun story
for the pop no no no no I'm not mad at
it it's long but I encourage you look
kayaker pretending that after crocodile
attack they never found him presumed
dead you think yeah that's the guy
that's 2010 though 2010 might have been
2010 13 years ago a long time ago okay
well that's himself there you go a
little long a little long time ago Dude
crocodiles and hippos there are three
ton hippos that will bite you in half
yeah now why would you like hippos are
more dangerous than Crocs when you're in
a stupid [__] entire thing Pros cons
you're the kayak going down the Congo
River what's the point bro yeah they
were in the yeah cozy
stay out the banks because the Crocs are
having a bake and might fancy you for
lunch stay off the banks
basically stay close behind me and
follow my lead any questions uh-huh
okay
we're set by the tragic acts and express
our deepest sympathies if you're if
that's your brother husband whatever
cousin you'd be so mad at me right I
would man take a look at how small
they're [__] like be if you if like
next week's like did you hear about
Brian like what what do you mean like
dude he decide randomly go down the
Congo River in a small kayak with
crocodile infested waters I go
[__] that's like Louis CK and
Rogan talking about if you're from
Connecticut and you got eaten by tigers
you [__] up like we figured this out
yeah you got it
yeah there it is that's the guy Hendrick
cozy
do you think like his wife and she was
just his girlfriend I think he's alive
no his girlfriend was waiting for him
and Jesus Christ they never found his
body but that's what happens when you
[__] around with giant Crocs and you're
that he wrote a book The Best Day Ever
yeah he he had a problem he had a
problem he was addicted to Adrenaline
and he couldn't stop he'll probably be
addicted to looking at Crocs in the eye
yeah and then one just that's part of it
the other they're cute man like at night
when they shine like you see the little
eyes nothing cuter than a hippo I'm very
afraid of them oh I'm terrified of all
that [__] not for me you're not afraid
of sharks
I'm afraid of them go back yeah let me
see that uh William the the hairy Rhino
they found
so all his organs are intact what's that
below that's crazy
that's his dick
keep going down stay down let's see if
he says anything here
preserved in ice for tens of thousands
of years it still has a thick reddish
brown hair all of Slim's most internal
organs glutenants intestines so we can
see what he ate and [__]
hmm it's basically stupid
[Music]
is that a horse
yeah look at Eric's stupid face when he
calls
[Laughter]
can you put it on the camera would you
answer that would you answer that that's
like I did that shout out there video on
my Instagram he's wearing a hat he's so
fast like that hat really brings out
your nose
I wonder what other animals they're
gonna find
um how how can they still not determine
[__] whether T-Rex had uh feathers or
not
um like how have we not found some of
that [__] I think it happened and then
and then you know when they when they
analyze their like voice box you know in
Jurassic Park everyone's like yeah
they're saying it was like
[Music]
yeah you ever seen that thing which says
it's the gay T-Rex and it gets up
anything you smell out and he's all hi
that was so funny it's so funny
that's right
uh
paleontologists think feathers may have
first of all to keep dinosaurs warm not
very warm but while young T-Rex probably
had a thin coat of Downy feathers an
adult T-Rex would not have need feathers
day warm so they did look like that well
when you have you been to Africa
absolutely not okay so no desire to go
when you go to Africa in the morning at
certain times of the year it can get
down to 30 degrees but check out Kenya
it would be the reptiles
well no you'll see like it's so [__]
cold like so cold and you know look at
that 30 degrees like freezing dude
freezing
um
yeah hey 30 to 35 Celsius in 20-25
Celsius at night is not cold okay what
is it called very hot can yet let me see
that what's the coldest month in Kenya
July
and of course month
63.63 Fahrenheit okay so it's not that
cool hey Brian
hey buddy
memories okay the point is
bring down jackets and the the board
with my story
any of the stories okay B it's not true
Kenya gets freezing no Kenya was
probably doesn't uh 55 degrees below the
very low
sorry we're no that's better yeah that's
still shirt short weather that's pretty
cool guys when you wake up you're in t
tank I mean 55 degrees seven degrees
pretty cold guys so to my point hey
that's two months and it says it's the
at the daily average is 73. yeah pretty
nice pretty nice pretty nice it can't be
cold if you have a cold it's not
terrible if you're chill to begin with
that can be a little cold sometimes
is dinosaurs were freezing in the 73
degree weapons so and it had feathers
yeah
watch this you pieces minus 24. that's
pretty cool that's cool that was in
1935.
hey man okay just give it up Africa's
hot well I'm just saying you know
sometimes there are elephants up there
too so
at four degrees below I think it's hot
yeah well [__] uh when we had to go
back to the storm in uh Dallas all those
animals and those hunting reserves died
yeah don't care hey do you um did you
feel the earthquake last night no but I
heard there was an earthquake when I was
in Dania oh no there was an earthquake
last night then I thought it was a dream
my house was going
you know the first thing I thought of
and I'm a bad person I thought my fish
blame my kids
fishy fishes I know I don't want them
4.2 been in California south of Malibu
that's right by me dude my whole house
my buddy my buddy actor first year I was
in LA he was from New York he was you
live in Venice yeah he goes why would
you do that what do you mean
everything's built on sand
why would you do that you know the big
one's coming and it's coming soon I go
what do you mean he goes earthquake
and you're on Sand and your house is
going to fall on you and you're gonna
die and everybody down there is going to
die so why would you do that get out
dead serious I was like gonna take my
chances and roll the dice well some
people think that too some people think
I do like Rogan was like I'd never buy a
house in Malibu you're on those things
about the Tsunami comes like
I'm Gonna Roll the Dice dude I don't
think that's gonna happen while I'm
alive yeah I'm gonna roll the dice yeah
I think we're good I'm Gonna Roll the
Dice uh and then oh guys I don't want
this 10 million dollar mansion on the
beach it's got It's on still no is that
near the beach oh that scares me yeah
I'll pass I'll go to the valley yeah no
thanks well it's like when me and Jerry
on a boat I told you I go see this is my
thing I've been thinking about this
lately I'm thinking about buying a boat
because why I go because let's say like
that movie The Last of Us really
happened or zombies came they can't
drive both dude I jump on that boat I
[__] get out then James
that's stupid what do you mean okay so a
you don't have to drive a boat B you're
in the middle of the Pacific Ocean and
you're just gonna fish or yeah I mean
the kids just live off fish and eat the
fish and stuff he was right right I'd
rather die yeah and I go what are you
gonna use nothing just sit there while
they eat and that's a good time until
storms hit he was he was I'd rather die
he was and then you can come back and
everybody's zombies and dead you want to
live in that world in it fair point yeah
I watched uh the first episode is very
good it's so well done and I was you're
right first 10 minutes I'm like oh
you're right away you're in I'm in isn't
it so good so good you know do you ever
watch Hunters on uh Prime it's Al Pacino
it's Al Pacino and see if it's a true
story chin it seems like it would be so
remember when all the Nazis World War
II's over the Nazis fled Germany yeah
bottom think they went to South America
yes NASA brought a lot here Operation
Paperclip and then there's a lot in
America yes well this shows about these
Nazi Hunters they find those Nazis are
trying to fit in with the America and
around the world trying to get rid of
their Nazi history that has to be a true
story right so inspiring events yes oh
wow so so a lot of Eli weasel and and
different uh different people mostly
mostly Jewish uh after World War II went
to find people like Dr Mengele and all
these like awful people horrible Doctor
Who uh
um concentration prison guards wardens
went and hunted them down and in most
cases found them and brought them back
to Israel and they were hung like
Eichmann they should be yeah they should
be and they were hung in it but but um
well did you see that there were Nazi do
you see that document like the monster
next door and he was like a legit I
didn't see it oh bro he was a legit
legit Nazi guard right the worst of the
worst was it the guy was he was it him
it was him they put him on trial
you know even the secretary that wrote
all the stuff in the construction camps
the Nazi secretary yeah they got her on
murder for like 7 000 people because she
was you know part of it yep the devil
next door oh it's good I gotta watch
that oh that's fantastic
man
Ivan the Terrible that's right Jesus
real pieces that's him huh that's him
that's really and he was like no to you
know these people are old their memories
are [__] up and she's like no [__] I
was there
that's him right there sadistic [__]
piece of [__] but he faked like he was
real sick and couldn't stand trial and
they're like get the [__] out of here
oh dude how about my buddy to bring this
game show back on network TV I won't see
what the show is but when they did it
back in the day in the 50s they have a
panel of comics and someone comes on and
you got to figure out who's telling a
lie this is the show it's fun right
about old school
this is a real episode they bring this
guy and he's an old man and he's and uh
his lie right it's a so there's like
five people come out tell your story one
of them's uh true the rest of our lives
this old man cannot tell the story goes
I was too row or whatever I was in in
the same theater when Lincoln was shot
think about when that was and this guy's
like 90 or whatever that was 18. he was
I was a little boy yeah and he was I was
a little boy I was in my parents were on
the theater I was there you'd have to be
150 years old well now you know this is
in the 50s no this is like 1955. yeah
it's 1955. wow yeah and so people like
doesn't make sense whatever it was true
he was one of the there's a picture he's
flying 90 years old he always like 90
something he was a little boy and he was
in the same theater right next to
Lincoln was here he was here with his
parents and Lincoln got shot here that'd
be crazy who shot Lincoln James Earl
Booth James Earl Jones James Brooks I
mean is it weird how they have three
names yeah James never give your kid
three names yeah my girl's middle name
I don't want to kill the president
yep they all have three names
Lee Harvey Oswald wait was it just was
yeah James John Wilkes Booth Joe did who
shot uh who shot
um uh Martin Luther King
um which they think is a huge conspiracy
but whatever uh Ray um they're all
conspiracies right I think it was except
for Lincoln they're like James Earl Ray
James
yep
uh huh weird right
very weird
look at him
and apparently when he shot him he
wasn't like it was not at the height of
his career either like a lot of his uh
like we need to have uh speeches back
then like Gatherings very minimal people
wasn't a ton it wasn't like when he's
booming it was like the tail end of it
too people always forget that
really wonder I don't know I was in a
round back then well I mean even now
with like the Trump Biden when they do
the big you know the big uh whatever
like um speeches or whatever is it
speech debates or what no not the
debates when they do the rallies when
that's the rallies people take picture
like Trump like look no one's there but
then I see on TV and there's like you're
killing people there they'll be like
look no one's at Biden's but then you
see that nothing is it so they can
manipulate the camera and go so I don't
know what's real unless you're actually
physically there I don't know
it's also like you know you saw that
Buffalo Bills that um
um that player right that three
September the field is that the game on
yeah Saturday there's all these
conspiracy theories like that's fake
that's not him because he was in The
Mask yeah and they're like you can't
tell there's no real good shot of them
then the starting quarterback went on a
pocket so forget to watch podcast
podcast he's wearing a Daniel Ricardo
howdy hat shout out to Dan Ricardo but
he gets on there and he's like hold up
we saw him we saw Demar Hamlin he was in
our locker room you idiot he was with
his kid his wife he spent the entire day
with us and then he went to the booth
stop this [__] stop it but man
conspiracies just go [__] like
wildfired guys stop everything can't be
a conspiracy no cool I know that's what
I tell my dear friend Sam well Tripoli
was blast out like very suspect here and
text me he's like dude you believe this
Mike
no yeah I believe in yeah I think he was
actually there dude yeah like you think
the entire team's in on this yeah
nobody's interested I think the NFL's
just putting a fry I don't think he's
doing well yeah no dummies no no that's
not how it works
[__] dummies especially this day and
age so like someone's being a snitch I'm
like hey that's not Hamlin died from the
covert vaccine that's replaced by a body
double uh-huh
really and the body double and people
are like uh hey Brandon like hello I'm
Brendan uh-huh like I'm Hamlin his
teammates wouldn't notice that because
body doubles are super easy is he a CIA
guy who's wearing Demar Hamlin's face
yeah people like yes hello how are you
I'm Brian it's weird right all right
what else you got to change you have
some current events
alrighty oh the oh wait we have
something
dude if it's a flower head I'm gonna
freak if it's a flower it was a flower
porn I'm gonna bust I call flowerhorn
flower heads oh here we go
you cutie happy birthday guys 200 years
old this is so sweet
I am happy birthday you guys this is the
best birthday present ever no
yay
where'd you guys get the cake
all cakes matter see half black half
white I like that now here now you know
I can't eat that right because my
psoriasis
I only eat Carnival
how's that like what kind of icing is it
um
hey actually a lot of people have been
hitting me up about psoriasis because
you were talking about it and I had it
post a picture and they want to know
what to do I'm going to tell you this
you can go to Dan Garner nutrition he
changed my life
um so a lot of it is is your gut they
think it's your gut uh Thief
at the Cleveland
Dermatology institute
that's a lemon that's a lemon on the
left or is my taste buds off I love Jack
team in my mouth I'll check a few canoe
um in Cleveland yeah
I'll get the number of you guys Dan
Garner nutrition Dan Garner nutrition
we call them spots
he's amazing he's a [__] genius
team Garner right there no more coach
Garner yeah right there
genius now he's great and then and then
just tell us what you did gut biome and
he works with the Cleveland Institute of
Dermatology and they work on psoriasis
hey hey you're doing again like you did
your crocodile story what'd you do to
get rid of the spots dude work on your
gut your gut profile that does not off
means nothing it might be off would you
take there it is right there yeah but
what did you take Brian
um
I took a probiotic protocol I did an
Elimination Diet like you were doing
yeah and then I did a probiotic protocol
but I can't tell you what that is these
guys at Pete ganoon that's his son great
guy he studied it I mean his father is a
Pioneer assistant
that's how they name their son what's
his name a thief there you go yes
great guy
um yeah people like because I was like I
posted a picture say I was grilling a
bunch of steak Yeah and it was for tires
the only thing you need he loves my
steak so I went to the store bought fish
and steak but Oscars from uh the fish
store and then got steak not cooking
fish right fish are friends not food so
I cooked some steak I post some like
about to get rid of these uh about to
get rid of these spots with psoriasis
shout out to the carnivore diet and
people were like man I didn't know that
worked people like it doesn't oh really
Jordan Peterson swears by it yeah so
what they think that does the carnivore
diet from a scientific perspective is
when you eat just one thing like that
you shut down the bad bacteria in your
gut yes and your gut kind of resets now
a lot of people do uh like a Paleo like
pescetarian diet or they do the
Mediterranean diet I for me do whatever
the [__] you want whatever works I just
know carnivore for me as far as getting
in shape and getting rid of these spots
is gonna be the best thing let's also
look at our stress levels oh that's
number one number one I have to fire
some people number one
um
number one
oh
I told you this what I gotta worry about
is because I post that I didn't my dad's
let's use my social media and he was
like Hey saw your posts about psoriasis
man some of the comments like they're
already read comments he goes well I'll
joining you know I talked to my doctor
he was here's what I'm worried about
because my dad got diabetes at my age
because he went through a divorce and he
had really bad stress and he's bankrupt
probably eating crazy yeah it wasn't
working out and he's like just when you
know it's a precursor because uh you're
gonna have you know psoriasis for life
this precursor diabetes it's not helpful
that and also well he was just no he had
a good point he's like he was like you
got to do something he's like and I know
you you'll be on it but don't be like me
just uh he goes I ignored it and then I
live with [__] you were running a
diabetes you were running a little too
hard I still running hard yeah
well there's there's you got to stop for
a second no I'm like Vin Diesel I live
my life one quarter mile at a time one
quarter mile at a time I live my life
one fish at a time one fish at a time
you gotta wrap it up today don't you
soon no no I pushed it okay join us help
me out nice go ahead and uh current
events yeah so uh Georgie so I for your
birthday I clipped out my favorite part
of man too you're awesome buddy and
Brian Collins bus special uh yeah it's
so fun yeah by far your best special
very good thank you can you imagine this
is your worst it just stays in your life
I'm really psyched about the new stuff
I'm writing this yeah that's your best
special I suggest you so that's cool
what else you got well no I'm gonna play
the clips real quick it's uh two minutes
I can't watch myself she gets straight
A's she thinks she's smarter than I am
because she's learning [__] in school
that I forgot
[Music]
that I forgot roll your eyes at me more
you know I know I can do better but
could be a lot worse a little respect
like you're welcome for everything first
of all dude she's so condescending she
corrects me the other day I was like
that's a good metaphor she was like well
that's not a metaphor that's a simile
true story
the other day in front of her friend she
goes wait he doesn't know all the layers
of the atmosphere
uh you know I know
I know so I wish I was you know some
cultures they're like
why don't you wear those cakes anymore
those are great those are so sick it's
not that sometimes you know look if you
have kids you know what I'm talking
about but I think it's not that I want
to slap my daughter I love her so much
don't like her sometimes but no but I
don't want to Survivor but sometimes
like I think that's one of the options
that presents itself when I'm scrolling
through
ways I'd like to shut her face off right
I'd love to push a pie in her [__]
face I went in the middle of one of her
know-it-all sentences and another thing
hope you get diabetes
fall back
deep
but then I remember that she's you know
she she's 14. and she still takes an
anime very seriously yeah like yeah it's
so funny the other day she came in
outraged she was like do you know that
some people think Todoroki is actually
related to Deku
that's nuts
I don't have anything in common with her
but uh you know what I was really
thinking when she said that this is
really what when she said that I was
like oh my God I cannot believe you're
going to be able to vote in less than
four years
Georgie I love this you gotta bring back
those uh [__] Irish green golden
gooses those are they're sitting them I
never wear them I should start wearing
them so sick right look how good they
look at this a dope ass outfit that's a
good outfit and if you haven't went and
watched man tears go do it I promote it
on my Twitter this weekend during the
fight you did yeah because I tweetened
out live tweets during the fights oh my
God yeah and I said I said something
like if he if this guy wins on bro Brian
special hey
about those fights you guys want to do
real quick we can I mean uh what do you
want to talk to me I didn't really have
much to say about it though the Jamal
Hill Globe protect Sarah well those
fights a lot of them were just
landslides like just an [__] it's
like if you're watching a college
football game they're up 60 to nothing
in the same quarter like all right I'm
good the Jamal Hill fight was kind of
like that even though Glover had him in
some compromising positions throughout
the fight you always believed in Glover
pull it off but everyone's young and
anyone who's a UFC fan it's nothing
against Jamal I love Jamal I've had
Jamal and not Glover so I love Jamal 6-4
huh yeah he's tall kid yeah he's about
yeah he's my size good you know is he
brought big guys hard to make that one
no he can do heavyweight Maybe
maybe listen he's fine that light
heavyweight but um yeah I think
everybody's rooting for globe you you
root for the underdog even though
Gloria's favorite because in Brazil yeah
there's just so many questions on Jamal
Hill it's like can he go five rounds
Kenny uh withstand the grappling of
Glover can he not only not Clover out
but if he does land a good shot we know
Glover's not going away unless you're
Anthony Rumble Johnson which rest in
peace there's nobody that hits like him
yeah so there's all these like questions
going into the fight so they get the
show's in Tampa on Friday everyone's a
guy who who you bet and I was like ah
I'm not calling it man there's too many
questions on Jamal Glover's older I
don't I don't like the it's the style
it's good for Glover I don't know he's
too old man it's tough to bet on now you
know uh John Hackleman shout out to John
Hackman one of the greats he wanted to
throw in the towel because obviously
he's went through it with Chuck seen
what Chuck's in with so he wanted to
throw the Talon for Glover and I think
the third or fourth they told him no he
retired from corner guys he went I'm out
I don't blame you're not gonna listen to
me I'm [__] I don't blame him me
neither good for you man yeah because a
fighter is too tough for his own good
fighter will die in there well that's
what Glover said he goes I gotta retire
I'm too tough I'm too tough amount yes
like I'll stay here taking all that
damage I hated watching that I hate
watching a great like Glover to chair
get [__] up like that he said I'm
telling you man it's how I feel about
tea City I I was I thought it was a
[__] outrage I really did you keep
that kid in there he's beautiful that
you you know what you remember you and I
argued about them like what the [__] you
talking about because I've come from
that background right like throwing it
out like [__] all you guys yeah well I
wouldn't listen to anything he said he
can't but the coach should have done
that I would have not but now we're
going down this road and I'm getting old
I'm kind of with you I'm like lived
outside another day he lost all good L's
and Hell whether you ate 200 punches or
three punches an L's an L that's right
you lost that's right you can throw the
Hail Mary a chance that's not good let's
do the smart thing tonight hey Bubba
number two guy in the world number one
guy in the world tonight let's go back
to the drawing board look save your
brain just make more money Tony good
person Justin gaichi they should have
stopped that Tony Ferguson again too
tough for his own good he was taking so
much head trauma Justin Gates of sitting
down on those punches
I mean and you see you at one point uh
Tony Ferguson looked like a a giant
mouse a hallucinogenic [__] Mouse and
then the other so Glover retired that
night figurito loses to Brown Marino 35.
so but you put his gloves down you're
like oh [__] he's gonna be tired no he
just retired up
125 is going to 35 and then Shogun his
last hurray it's just that has been
fighting since 19. he won The Pride
Grand Prix I think he's 19. I mean holy
[__] but here's what's weird is
I just wish the UFC did a better job
like his send-off fight should have been
against another Legend
like why they give These Guys these
young up-and-comers to get annihilated I
don't know I don't I hate but you to me
you have to you have to earn your right
to fight those guys like I have to earn
my right to fight Crow cop right I
knocked four guys out I knocked out a
Gonzaga before I had to earned that yes
I beat Crow cop I had to earn the right
to fight no gear in Brazil you have to
earn those rights because those guys
have paid all the price to be at that
level yeah so in order win or lose the
fact that I shared lock on with Gonzaga
with Travis Brown with no Gear with
crocop is an honor win or lose that's a
big [__] deal absolutely you've
already won if you sign a contract to
fight any of those guys
in order to Shogun a legend the guy that
he fought couldn't tell his name bad
with names
like I didn't earn it that's what's nuts
it's like I agree
yeah but they they should be celebrating
these guys give him a royal send-off
they should have called trioga and go
this is your last fight in Brazil who
would you like
now of course shogun's like I want
[__] you know whatever Izzy or you
know some crazy Alex Pier or some some
crazy fight 205 have those guys come up
no no we're gonna give you another guy
like-minded another 205 or that you know
that's gonna be a tough matchup for you
but it's winnable like Frankie Edgar's
send out fight shouldn't be against that
Savage
tears or whatever it should be against
Donna Cruz another Legend yes like why
[__] these guys over do better like why
do that I don't understand it I don't
understand like Rob Robbie Lawler and
ideas that makes sense absolutely two
legends absolutely not some young line
who can take all the shots and tear your
[__] face off that we don't know
give these guys the problem yeah instead
of taking all that damage and being
totally outclassed because the guy
they're just like his last fight should
have been he should have fought someone
who he probably had a leg up on let him
win the last fight and right after the
sunset all all this [__] all the Blood
and Tears that they sweat that they put
in for the the business I agree this is
what he yes that's the yeah the answer
is what would you say that's how yes the
answer is yes the answer is yes and and
you know you'll you'll you'll entertain
us entertain us not to entertaining
tonight's slap feet slap Fight League I
will watch that be I will never there's
my [__] you know when someone's like
dude don't watch this porno there's like
nine what black guys some little girl
you're like let me just see what's going
on in yeah that's how I was slappling
like Dana promote I'm like this is
[__] stupid like hey babes that's DVR
it's just like it's just such a circus
yeah and
it's such a circus you can't take your
eyes off of it it's not gonna be around
in four weeks because the backlash and
the numbers are terrible they should
just call CT
fast road to CT they should just call it
Dana it's really [__] it Friday
because all y'all getting CT the point
of the show is to get CT ain't nobody
walking out over there without CT that's
facts God now did you hear the the slap
leak reached out to a current UFC
fighter like hey you interested in doing
this he he blasted out how much they
offered him you know what those children
were making how much you think it's
gonna make me so sad
how much you think to get slapped on
national TV and you got a gut I bet you
I bet you it's
I bet you it's five grand oh you're cute
two and two two if you show two if you
win
now hold on two grand yeah hold on
what's this sound like
does this not sound like the UFC 10
years ago yeah
is the UFC just not recreating a model
that they that they took advantage of
athletes and Fighters and because the
backlash of the public now they have to
pay Fighters because we realize what
they're risking with their lives did the
UFC just go how can we expose people
more
slap Fight League these morons will take
what we give them they're repeating
history dude it's 2023 those poor guys
are granted like well they didn't ask
them to do it I get it you're not doing
slap by league if you have a lot of
other options
they're doing the same game model that
they did in the 90s when they [__]
people over they're just doing and
they're throwing it in your face
and y'all dumbasses are watching it and
I'm one of them
I can't get enough of it I'll never
watch it I will never watch I just have
to tune in because it's not enjoy it
like it won't be around there's no
[__] chance there's nothing that
things you end up on uh UFC Fight Pass
yeah there's TBS like this is hey it's
if it was doing millions of views TBS
like well these people are watching it's
debut with all that promotion from the
UFC mind you nobody wants it I think 300
000 people yeah the same amount of
people that watch and listen to this
total 300 000 episodes where we get same
as fightly thinking about your promotion
they got from the UFC and you you hit as
many ears and eyeballs as we do [__]
and we don't get CD or slap each other
and be out of shape ah
and how dice you will get when a
transgender girl is like you know what
[__] I feel like I could be World Champ
in this and some 300 pounds former Navy
SEAL gives like I Feel Like a Woman
say less
clap yeah
yeah
I
I would do that with you
you just I'll do a slap fight with you
you know it's your birthday yeah I don't
want to do that to you and I have to
stand like this and you just go cut this
dude you just sit there like this
just like
do you think all their parents are
watching One
two now we tried we [__] tried man
I'd be more proud of my son if he's
working in the ditches blowing his back
out you know putting cement on a [__]
sidewalk
I'd be much more proud of my kids if
they're doing that thing slap tune to
bye buddy
those heavyweight Russian guys with no
no necks
giant guys with like chalk on their
hands I like arm wrestling give me arm
wrestling that's cool do you it's all
right hey the favorite was the MMA
fighters everybody who had sugar in the
tank and was like
oh I don't know and the guy's like oh
cool
and he popped he's like oh here and then
Dana's like well this guy was MMA
fighter he might be able good of this
he's all oh
y'all oh my dude quit flicking your
wrist oh no and then Daniel's like see
everyone just thinks just because the
MMA fighter equivalates this uh slap
Fight League it's like nobody thinks
that why would Dana do that though does
he need more money or I don't get it
that was my whole rant on the shop show
how much money do you need
all they're doing is because the UFC is
not fighting the unions and stuff are
coming they're gonna have to start folk
forking out a lot more money for the
fighters so the UFC goes all right who
can we Expose and take advantage of
before because the UFC they're coming we
got to change our business model to make
more money off some poor sucker in their
CT slap Fight League
two and two you'll make more money more
benefits me way cooler people and save
your brain cells if you work at [__]
you ever see that arm wrestling calls
himself the arm wrestling Whisperer and
he's like this he'll arm wrestle guys
not a big guy and he's like oh yeah
yeah oh [__]
[__] is strong and they beat them it's
like a really sexual watch
oh no not him now that's the guy but
Devin laurent's too big but like
um
random guy beats Devin the rat no no
he's like oh yeah yeah look at your hand
look at your head this guy right there
yeah yeah
so funny just get him there where he's
talking like you gotta move it with a
guy's teaching he's like look Jan Put
Your Shoulder line up your shoulder yeah
[__] strong
That helmet's Dope he wears his helmet
too that's it that's what you're here
fight it beat it beat it beat it up see
that it's not him it's the big guy yeah
the big guy he's beating that's that's
the best in the world Devin the rat yeah
but he's the one that talks they call
him the arm wrestler whisper not the guy
you're talking about the armrest thing
Whisperer he's doing it back to him
that's why he's doing it back to him
he's so funny and he's doing it back to
him
because he'll go I'm gonna go a little
bit I'm gonna go he's doing it right
back I'm not nearly as famous look he's
going back at her he's the best in the
world defining her out here it is a cool
kind of community isn't it yeah he's
great he's great that's funny
um
one more time you ever done any arm
wrestling buddy
hold on I got a guy who can teach you
though and you can compete
what what happened plus you can pull
weights and stuff what oh you tell
people about our strength competition
gripper you know see your tensile
strength and uh Bam Bam over here did so
I did my best is 119.
um my brother-in-law did 143 or
something big tall George did one thirty
something 136. he did 144. he's a big
boy yeah and uh you did 198. is that
good that's crazy hi
that's pretty hot you got them big palms
and you can see these big Palms
Springfield Missouri yeah blue Comedy
Room yeah February third and fourth all
right Saturday only come on now people
just oh look at his fist yeah so I'm uh
in Springfield Missouri I think it's
about an hour outside the Ozarks I want
to peep out the Ozarks to do some
fishing Springfield Missouri February
3rd and 4th Naples Florida will also be
doing fishing out there February 16th
through the 18th Bakersfield California
one night only that things almost sold
out February 23rd get your tickets right
now Brea one night only February March
3rd to the fourth of the big ass fight
companion we have Rampage Jackson a very
special guest and jelly roll for the
fight campaign March 4th Jon Jones
return that's why I had to cancel the
shows on the fourth sorry guys uh
Oklahoma City's March 9th through 11th
get your tickets at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com in one month Edmonton comic
strip Edmonton Canada
I will be at the comic strip February 23
24 25 then I go right over to Nashville
Tennessee Zanies March 2 3 and 4. and
then New York New York Sony Hall March
11th bro you're flying into Manhattan
flying back to LA then back to West
that's right buddy and then I go to West
Nyack
that's Nyack March 16 17 18 11 8 live
come get some all right kids love you
Springfield Missouri see you next week
love you guys Happy Birthday B happy
birthday Brian thanks guys